-Performing his new single,
"RUN,"
with a little help
from The Roots,
DJ Cutmaster Swiff,
and Georgia Me,
once again, Killer Mike!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-These souls of Black folk
ain't no joke.
Full of joy, resilience,
the epitome of hope.
Just in how we cope,
day to day,
through this maze of America,
we learn how to play and master.
Had no choice but to jump
higher, run faster, move quick.
They plaster god's images
criminal in every flick.
In every aspect of media,
a lie's what they feeding ya.
But I'm here to teach ya, bruh,
we the truth.
Equipped to overcome,
we them ones.
You a winner out the gate,
shawty, run!
It's how you look at the world
you been put in
because of your skin.
Will I succumb or be
a casualty of evil
or am I gonna fight to the end?
Am I committed to the
progression of my people
or we gonna let the state
killing us be a trend?
Fight.
We always win.
It's part of our legacy.
From plantations to presidency,
release the hesitancy
and become emboldened.
We sure ain't
what they said we'd be.
We Black,
so you know we holding.
Through holding back 'cause the
movement's never done.
Set your sights.
Run, god, run.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-New York City.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Go to church.
♪♪
♪ God don't like ugly,
I ain't one to judge (judge) ♪
♪ Whole, whole lot of gold
Cubans weigh a ton (ton) ♪
♪ Say I kept it solid when
it's all said and done (done) ♪
♪ All I know is keep goin',
run, better run (run) ♪
♪ Mama told me, Never fold,
♪ Like Jenny told Forrest Gump,
Run, better run (run) ♪
♪ The race for freedom ain't
won, run, better run (run) ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Get out the red clay,
run, better run (run) ♪
♪ The west side of Atlanta,
yeah, that where I'm from ♪
-♪ Flatland, flatland ♪
-♪ Outside, I was hands-on
like a glove (Batman) ♪
♪ Movin' like my guy N.O.R.E.,
eatin' on the run (run, run) ♪
♪ Still an underground king
and that's word to Bun (Bun) ♪
-♪ Ooh, ah ♪
-♪ Locked in like Rice Street
without a bond ♪
-♪ Friends, friends, friends ♪
-♪ I was playin' with the powder
way before LeBron ♪
-♪ Ooh, ah ♪
-♪ My wife was born a redhead
and now she a blonde (blonde) ♪
♪ Politicians lie and your
favorite rapper is a con (con) ♪
♪ Don't check for me
without a check for me ♪
♪ That's a hund (bluest) ♪
♪ The only L's I wear
is followed by Vuitton (Louis) ♪
♪ Get money and the power,
teach 'em while they're young ♪
♪ Blessed to make it out the
slum, run, better run (run) ♪
♪ All I know is keep goin',
run, better run (run, run) ♪
♪ Mama told me, Never fold,
run, better run (run) ♪
♪ Like Jenny told Forrest Gump,
Run, better run (run) ♪
♪ The race for freedom
ain't won, run, better run ♪
♪ This for the ones
that never won (won) ♪
♪ Hurt feelin's goin' numb
(numb) ♪
♪ Beat the odds
like a drum (drum) ♪
♪ Run, run, better run
(run, run, take off) ♪
♪ Run, run, better run (run) ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Run, better run (run) ♪
♪ Mama told me, Never fold,
run, better run (run) ♪
♪ Like Jenny told Forrest Gump,
Run, better run (run) ♪
♪ The race for freedom
ain't won, run, better run ♪
♪ This for the ones
that never won (won) ♪
♪ Hurt feelin's goin' numb
(numb) ♪
♪ Beat the odds
like a drum (drum) ♪
♪ Run, run, better run (run) ♪
-♪ Run ♪
-♪ Run, run, better run (run) ♪
-♪ Better run ♪
-Church, gospel, Amen.
-♪ Run ♪
-♪ Runnin' ♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!